hello i'm peter sullivan i'm post-doc in
the aurentis lab at seattle children's
research institute
thank you for joining me as i discuss
some progress developing an ftfr
targeted r
for the treatment of rhabdomyosarcoma
rhabdomyosarcoma or rms
is a cancer of soft tissue and comes in
two main varieties
embryonal or alveolar
rms
erms
is a fusion negative
subtype and acts primarily as
eraseopathy and affects younger children
arms however is effusion positive
subtype it is characterized by the
chromosomal translocation resulting in
tax-3 foxo1 fusion protein
currently the only treatment for rms is
chemotherapy and the 5-year survival
rates are very low particularly among
patients with recurrent disease
furthermore survival rates have not
improved for sarcomas since the 1980s
highlighting the need for new forms of
therapy
the studies of the underlying biology of
rms have found that these tumors arise
at multiple developmental time points
uh kind of shown here in the top left
arms
can arise from either mesodermal cells
and all the way to the very left here
or it can rise from the mature muscle
cells on the right side of the spectrum
the rms however primarily arises kind of
in the middle of the spectrum for the
myoblast population
and on the right you can see that the
rms the fusion positive subtype is
driven largely by the introduction of an
infinite enhancer loop
of the pax 3 myo1 d1
myog and foxo transcription factors
so we go from stepwise progression
to
more of a loop progression
which is what drives tumorogenesis
another important aspect of rms biology
is a low mutation burden
most pediatric tumors have low tumor
mutational burden compared to adult
tumors shown in this graph on the bottom
left
and this suggests that there are very
few neoantigens or the immune system to
be able to target
largely because rms has a low mutation
tumor mutation burden and no identified
specific targets for small molecule
therapy we believe that rms could be a
candidate for chimeric antigen receptor
or car t cell therapy
this therapy uses t cells engineered to
express
a receptor containing an extracellular
antibody fragment against a
tumor-associated antigen
and an intracellular
simulatory domain used to activate the t
cell as shown in this cartoon on the on
the right of the slide
car t therapy has now been tested in
many trials and has had much success in
hematological cancers
but has not shown the same responses in
solid tumors as demonstrated by the
clinical trial results summarized here
in the table
which mostly result in no objective
responses
knowing these challenges we set out to
design a car capable
of clearing rms tumors by developing a
highly effective car
then armoring these t cells against the
tumor micro environment to overcome the
unique challenges in solitude
the first step of this project was to
find and validate
target in rms
specifically we want to know which rms
specific surface proteins can be
targeted by cars
and can an rms directed car actually
control tumor growth in vivo
the rms targets were identified using
gene microarrays
comparing multiple types of pediatric
tumors against healthy tissues
first overall expressed
overall
the highly expressed transcripts were
identified
and these hits were filtered out for
cell surface proteins specifically
which is uh the only
molecules that a car would be able to
identify
and finally individually annotated for
the most likely candidates that could be
targeted by a car
from this we arrived at a much smaller
group of potential targets
so the top hits
from this process included m-cam ftfr4
activein and gpc2 along with other
several other cancer-associated genes
fgfr4 was chosen chosen as a strong
candidate that is as it is upregulated
upregulated
in both arms and erms
and is expected to have little to no
expression in healthy mature tissues
though several other candidates on this
list have also been selected for
development
to validate fgfr4 as a potential car
keeper uh target
uh my predecessors looked at fgfr4
expression
by immunohistochemistry in the top left
rna based gene expression on the bottom
left
and then total protein amounts shown on
the right
in each case we see that the tumor
tissues have much higher ftfr4
expression
than the healthy healthy tissues do
and on the right we see that even
among other tumor types ftfr4 is much
more highly expressed the rms specific
humor types shown in gray
compared to either the normal tissues
showing black or other cell lines shown
in white
this suggests that fgfr4 would be a good
car target as there's a little chance of
off tumor on target toxicity
as the healthy tissues show very low
expression of fpfr4
really work on this project led to the
development of a car that was able to
control tumors in an easier to treat
metastatic rms model
a significant reduction in the tumor
burden measured by levy vote imaging
and an increase in survival
as seen in this data here
however the same car was unable to
control intramuscular or atopic tumors
suggesting that further development
would be needed
furthermore when car t cells were
introduced
the tumors responded by producing more
stromal regions within the tumor
as seen all the way to the left in the h
and e staining
on the bottom with right on top we have
tumor alone on the bottom we have tumor
plus car t cells
you see that there's this lighter
colored strands which indicate stromal
regions and tumor
but only when we treat with car t cells
additionally the vast majority of cd8
and cd4 t cells
were localized to the stromal region
effectively blocking the car t cells
from reaching the lesion
additionally pdl1 expression was
upregulated
it's likely priming these t cells for
exhaustion this data provided early
hints about the tumor's defenses due car
t therapy that would need to be overcome
my role in this project was to improve
upon the previous cars by screening new
binding domains for ftfr4
i set out to answer whether we could
increase the efficacy of the fgfr4 car
and if this would be sufficient to
overcome the immunosuppressive
human microenvironment
working with our collaborators from
university of pittsburgh
they created
new ftf r4 binders using the phage
display library for huma fully human
binders
which included both scfvs as well as
single chain
binding
domains original bait molecule shown on
the top left
used the entire extracellular
domain of fgfr4
however we now know that targeting
membrane proximal regions
makes more effective cars
so we streamed a new bait molecule which
only included the ig-3 domain of fdfr4
and
from this collaboration we received
eight single chain binders
as well as
seven
scfe
binders
uh and the overall
structure of these is
shown in the cartoons on the left
for the seven scfbs we tested these in
both the heavy light and light heavy
chain orientations
binders were all fused to a cd8 hinge
and transmembrane domain
or 1bb costim and cd3 zeta domain
we assessed car surface antigenic
surface expression using biotinylated
ftfr protein
sustained four ftfr4 cars directly
we also assessed the cytokine production
looking specifically at interferon gamma
tnf alpha and il2 cytokines produced
in response to coca culture with target
cells
and not shown here
but we also assessed the cytotoxicity of
these cars against their target cell
lines
from this initial set of data
we selected the top five most promising
cars to further validate in vitro
interestingly we also observed
differences
in both cytokine and
cytotoxicity profiles
by changing the chain orientation from
life heavy to heavy light
is a critical step in selecting and
optimizing our cars
from our top candidates we assess the
top five
or cytotoxicity against
dense and rms cell line
specifically the rh-30 cell line
which we engineered to also express a
truncated cd19 or a positive control
on the left
we have cope we co-cultured car t cells
and rh-30 cells at varying effector to
target ratios
however we know that sarcomas are also
particularly sensitive to nk like
killing
which can show up as non-specific
killing in these ctl assays
on the right
we added unlabeled k562 cells at a 30 to
1 ratio with rh-30 cells to remove some
of this non-specific killing
from this data
we can see that two car candidates
particularly stand out
which are the 150 heavy light not 154
heavy light
so it's interesting that
of all of our candidates both of them
came from this heavy light uh category
and we're still looking into whether or
not this is a particular feature of
the architecture of the car or if this
is just a lock in the sense that these
two cars worked best
we also tested several other cell lines
for non-specific killing
we tested rajy cells showed very little
non-specific
killing by these car t cells
we also tested k562 cells
which
alone showed varying degrees of
non-specific killing
however when we used coal target
inhibition again uh with 31 to 30 to 1
ratio of
unlabeled cells
we see that most of this is non-specific
to the car
so this does give us some insight into
which of these cars are giving the
strongest off-target effects
and to test these further we did a
stress test for these five candidates
in which we repeatedly challenge the
cells every two days with additional
target cells
starting at either one to one shown on
top right graph
or a one to four ratio shown in the
bottom really graph
the cars were co-cultured with rh-30
cells for two days
and the remaining cell fractions were
determined by foil
which is what's plotted
and the original ratio is re-established
every two days
this reprocess was repeated for a total
of three challenges over six days
and as the grass on the right indicates
this assay helped us differentiate from
the car's ability to repeatedly kill the
tumor cells
and finally cytokine production of these
top candidates were tested and compared
to the original fgfr4 car
which are legal tiers m410 and m412
while several of the new cars
particularly stand out such as 146 and
151 are
all the new cars do substantially better
than the originals
giving us hope that these will have
better effects in vivo
and with all the in vitro data taken
together we chose to continue in vivo
with two of our top candidates for 154
hl and 150 150 hl
these were chosen for their specificity
improved cytokine production and ability
to respond to multiple rounds of target
cells
using nsg mice we injected rh-30 cells
expressing our truncated cd19
into the lake muscle
orthotopically
three days later we injected seven
million car t cells
either by iv or directly into the tumor
on day seven
however we still did not see any effect
of the fgfr4 cars in these orthotopic
tumors despite their improvement in
vitro
we were excited to note however that the
cd19 car used as a positive control
was able to delay tumor growth when
injected by iv or by inter-tumor
injection
this is suggested to us that the rms
tumors can be overcome but only under
the right conditions
we believe that this difference between
the fgfr4 car and the cd19 car is
largely due to the number of target
molecules present on the cell surface
the histogram on the left shows fgfr4
expression of several synchoma lines
with rh30 shown in orange
and with the quantification of the
molecules per cell
on the right
and rh 30s here compared to several
other ewing sarcoma cell lines
and so well fgfr4 is much more highly
expressed in the rmsl lines than others
it's still far
or about 30 fold lower
expression than the cd19 target on our
sellings
and this suggests that
the cv19 card is working better because
it seemed much more targeted
one way to overcome this this issue is
actually by lowering the threshold of
the fgfr4 car
so that it can work more effectively
against
a low density antigen
this might be a necessary process
for optimization strategy
for controlling rms tumors
in addition to the car t cells going
into the mice
we also need to overcome some of the
tumor defenses
to allow the fgfr4 cars to function in
vivo
for this we need to know what
defenses the tumor has
and to identify the most relevant
pathways in rms we compared rh-30 cells
in culture
with and without interfering gamma
treatments
mimic the response of t cells in vivo
the chart here shows the highest express
soluble factors
identified
and they are listed based on
rh30 treatment through
so each column here it shows a different
replicate
and the tc71
shown on the right side of this chart
was used as a uh
as a comparison
tc71 is a ewing sarcoma on
and some of the top hits that we
identified
for us to target include
macrophage migration inhibitory factor
uh
mis
beta
chemokine ccl24
leukemia inhibitory factor or lif
and i201
these soluble factors are all present in
many other tumors as well
which allowed us to build on the work
from others to target these pathways
either with small molecules
or by armoring our car
soluble factors were confirmed by elisa
assay in multiple rms cell lines so we
used rms 13 cell line rd
and rd rh30 which i showed you
previously
so here i'm showing several different
graphs of um
concentration of each of these soluble
factors after interfering gamma
treatment for either 24 or 48 hours
mif we only tested at 24 hours
and for each one of these cell lines
as you can see there's some variation in
response between cell lines
however for mif lif and tgf beta we do
see
increased amounts of these pro
these soluble factors
compared to either other tumors
or are upregulated upon interfering
gamma stimulation
so these are all likely important
pathways generalized to rms that we
should
and may have to target
and as indicated previously the
introduction of t cells into
tumor-bearing mice
causes these tumors to respond by
producing more spermal regions
on the top we have a mouse that only has
tumor on the bottom panels we have the
tumor plus t cells
unstained by h e
on the bottom you can see these long
strands of light colored fibers
indicating stromal regions within the
tumor
we mainly see these upon
t cell treatments
furthermore when these tissues are
stained using a trichrome stain
we see a bright blue stain which
indicates the presence of collagen
again this is much more
prevalent when we have activated t cells
in the
mice treated with activated t cells
now on the right here
we have immunofluorescent staining of
cd11b myeloid population
as well as cd3t cells
which are refined to be in close contact
with one another
and particularly localized within the
stromal regions
these results
paired with the previous data
in the early ftfr4 cars
suggest that these tumors are responding
to treatment by building up more stromal
regions
these regions are preventing t cells
from entering the tumor lesion itself
furthermore we know that there are
myeloid populations here so we have yet
to determine if these are
biological
derived suppressor cells
or tumor associated macrophages
so in conclusion
our early studies have defined a target
in rms to approach with car t therapy
fgfr4 is highly expressed in both fusion
positive and fusion negative rms
but not expressed in mature healthy
tissues
furthermore fdfr4 cars can control rms
tumors in a metastatic model
but not in but not yet an orthotopic
model
my role in this project is to build new
fgfr4 cars we have developed more
effective ftfr4 cars in vitro
by screening against a more membrane
proximal fragment of fgfr4
and while these new fgfr4 cars still do
not control orthotopic rms tumors
we do see that our positive control as
well
cd19 car is able to control
these tumors
suggesting that there is a potential for
cartoon therapy
or specifically rms tumors
the point i didn't elaborate on in this
too much in this talk
but important to note out is that the
intra-tumor delivery of car t cells did
not provide any benefit over the
intravenous delivery
this is likely because of the stromal
regions that develop
in the tumors
it's likely that our t cells are being
um
our t cells are weaving
tumor logician itself and being
specifically brought into stromal
regions where they have little to no
effect
on the tumor growth itself
and finally we define some of the tumor
defenses defenses that we need to
overcome
and delivery of t cells induces stromal
formation in rms tumors which prevents
the infiltration of t cells into the
tumor
likely through the action of mdscs
or tumor associated macrophages in the
resulting stroma
furthermore multiple salval soluble
factors in the tme
may prevent car t function including
gigf beta mif
lif and idol 1.
so
our next steps are to first optimize the
ftfr4car to function at a lower
threshold of target molecules
and two to overcome tumor
microenvironments i think both of these
approaches are going to be necessary in
this tumor model
we are building new tools to test these
hypotheses
we now have an mif lif
gcl24 and combined mif-lif knockout cell
lines or rms which we are testing in
vivo
additionally we are also targeting pdl1
signaling by using pd1 blocking
antibodies to see if that is sufficient
in
improving the function of these fgfr4
cars
and on the card engineering side
we're developing several new cars that
have been shown
by others who have improved in vivo
function
that will target molecule densities
as shown in this cartoon in the bottom
right
in summary rms like many other solid
tubers will take a targeted approach to
overcome
we're developing optimized cars
on with cars with multiple multiple
targets
and logic gated cars
we're also targeting many of the tumor
defenses such as tgf beta signaling
we're targeting lif mif ccl 24 soluble
factors
as well as pdl1pt1 signaling
and metabolic t-cell suppression from
idol one
in addition to these
molecular
defenses
we're also targeting
we're looking at the presence of
immunosuppressive cells such as
tumor-associated macrophages
and myeloid deprived suppressor cells
we believe that this multi-targeted
approach will be
necessary
but we'll be able to overcome rms tumors
may give hope for the sound therapy
where they're most desperately
desperately needed
finally i'd like to thank the many
people who contributed to this project
well as well as the funding sources
thank you for your attention